NARRATOR: By now
you might have seen
this picture, or one like it,
floating around the internet.
this is Dismaland, the
Banksy-created anti-amusement
park, put together to
spoof the Magic Kingdom.
And it looks pretty amazing.
But the dilapidated re-creation
of Sleeping Beauty's castle
and that warped statue
of the Little Mermaid
are just the beginning.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
One of the first people
to experience Dismaland,
and the man who took
this photo was this guy.
SASHA BOGOJEV: Hi, my
name is Sash Bogojev.
I'm from Croatia, and
I'm a senior writer
at arrestedmotion.com,
a website that
focuses on art shows
and art related events.
The photo was taken in
Weston-super-Mare in UK,
on 20th August 2015,
just after the door
of Dismaland Bemusement Park
opened for the exclusive press
review.
This was pretty
much the first thing
I saw when I entered
these [INAUDIBLE] grounds.
And being among the first
few lucky ones to witness it
in person, I instinctively
grabbed my camera
and started snapping photos.
NARRATOR: Dismaland came from
the mind of the elusive street
artist Banksy.
And no, that's not
actually a picture of him.
There really aren't any.
He travels the world, creating
thought-provoking street art
using mostly paint, dark
humor, and a public wall
to express his point you.
SASHA BOGOJEV:
Officially, this Dismaland
is Banksy's biggest
show today, which
is built around the idea
of creating a fanfare that
is as much fun as real life is
when we scratch the surface.
Sadly, the real life is far
from being glittery, happy,
and bright.
And I believe Banksy had
it in mind when he was
putting together this project.
Though, calling it
only an art show
would be an understatement,
because this thing
is much more than that.
NARRATOR: In some ways, it
is just an amusement work.
You walk in, wait in
lines, buy tacky souvenirs.
SASHA BOGOJEV: It's
definitely like no other park.
The rides are not build
to make you feel happy,
but instead they make you
feel awkward and comfortable.
The staff isn't happy either.
They're bored,
frustrated, and useless.
And the whole setting just
slams the weight of the world
into your face.
NARRATOR: But there is
a point to all this.
A reason for all ugly, sad, and
bizarre art and attractions.
SASHA BOGOJEV: Instead of
amusing kids and letting
them live in the
cloud's influence
by fake reality shows
and unreal expectations,
this spark shows us what the
real world actually looks like.
I believe the intention was
to make people uncomfortable,
to do the point
they actually have
to deal with their feelings
about certain issues.
Such as migration crisis, is
global warming, economy issues,
et cetera.
NARRATOR: There's also a
more succinct moral here.
This one suggested my Banksy.
SASHA BOGOJEV: I believe
the main message is actually
the one the artist
stated himself.
It's sorry kids.
NARRATOR: Looking for another
completely bizarre place?
Check out this
episode on exploring
the creepy and abandoned ruins
of the Chernobyl nuclear power
plant.
PERSON: Was one of the
top places on my list
that I want to see.
Not just for photographic
opportunities
and to explore the
buildings, but also
from a historical perspective.
NARRATOR: And as always,
don't forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.